Il nous parle de ce combat
contre les espèces
envahissantes.
- Le lac Massawipi, avec
ses 14 km d'eau claire et
profonde, est un plus beaux
lacs en Estrie. Mais une menace
est apparue l'an dernier
et elle inquiète assez
les riverains pour avoir
embauché ces plongeurs
de l'Aquarium du Québec.
Leur mission: retirer du lac
les moules zébrées qu'ils vont
trouver.
MARIE-PIERRE LESSARD, dir.
Conservation, Aquarium du Québec
- À comparer à l'année dernière,
on voit plus de moules zébrées,
ou grosses, aussi, celles-là
qu'on voit. À chaque fois
qu'on en enlève une, c'est
100 de moins qu'il va y avoir
l'année prochaine.
- Espèce envahissante qui
débalance l'écosystème partout
où elle prolifère, la moule
zébrée, est arrivée au Québec
il y a quelques décennies,
accrochée aux coques de bateaux
transatlantiques.
- Il y a 10-15 ans, on
en parlait seulement dans
le fleuve qu'il y a de
plus en plus de tests puis
de vérifications qui se font
avec le temps. Fait qu'on
se rend compte qu'il y en a
dans beaucoup plus de lacs
qu'on aurait pu penser.
- En Estrie, elles envahissent
déjà l'immense lac Memphrémagog,
comme en témoigne cette photo
prise après une plongée à la fin
mai. Mais l'eau du Memphrémagog
est moins riche en calcium
que celle du lac Massawipi,
qui pourrait devenir un paradis
pour la prolifération de
l'espèce.
- Elles vont absorber toutes
les particules dans l'eau qui
pourraient servir d'alimentation
pour d'autres espèces. Elles
peuvent s'installer dans tout
ce qui est prise d'eau. Donc
vraiment, puis ça ne fera pa
juste faire une couche après
la prise d'eau, ça peut
s'introduire à l'intérieur,
puis vraiment boucher les prises
d'eau.
- En avez-vous trouvé ailleurs?
- Inquiète, Michèle Gérin,
ce jour-là, attendait les
résultats de chaqu
- On en a sorti pas loin
d'une centaine dans la première
plongée.
- Son organisme, Bleu Massawipi,
a amassé 250 000 $ pour lutter
contre la moule zébrée.
MICHÈLE GÉRIN, directrice
générale, Bleu Massawippi
- Si le lac Massawipi perd
cette lutte-là, il est à
craindre, très probablement,
la contamination de tous
les lacs des Cantons-de-l'Est,
et plus encore.
- Il y a une bonne nouvelle :
l'invasion en est seulement
à ses débuts dans le lac.
on a choison a choison a choiso:
ici on ne laissait pas faire.
On peut pas s'en foutre, il y
aura des conséquences. Nous,
on nous dit qu'on va avoir
des tapis de moules zébrées :
on parle de coquilles parce
que ça vit trois ans.
Des coquilles ça d'épais
dans le fond du lac, là,
9]>$/o
On peut pas se baigner là
parce que c'est coupant!
- Dans la région, une opération
a été lancée pour sensibiliser
ceux qui vont de lac en lac.
HÉLÈNE DANEAU, mairesse, Hatley
- On a des stations barrées de
lavage des deux côtés de notre
lac. Ceci étant dit, c'est
sûr qu'une personne qui
a une descente privée qui
veut inviter des amis, qui
veut contourner pourra toujours
le faire. C'est pour ça, dans
le fond, que nous on met autant
d'emphase sur l'éducation.
- La moun'est pas
la seule espèce envahissante
que ces quelques minutes
de jet ouillanteouillanteouillae
peuvent freiner. Dans
les Laurentides, la composition
chimique de l'eau
les lacs de la moule, mais
un autre envahisseur gagne
du terrain.
- Tu reviendrais dans deux
semaines, tu capoterais!
Tiens, regarde!
- Oui il y en plein là...
- Le lac Maskinongé, à Mont-Tree
état. L'été n'est pas commencé
que déjà, le myriophylle à épis
pousse partout.
ANDRÉ LACHAPELLE, président,
Asso. résidents, lac Maskino
- Donc ça, c'est du myriophylle
à épis. Je déchiquète ça, ça
se met à flotter, il va se créer
sitôt que
le poids le permet, ça redescend
au fond et ça crée une nouvelle
plante.
- André Lachapelle, qui habite
le secteur depuis 30 ans, a vu
son lac dépérir. La baignade
y est encore permise, mais
l'eau n'en donne pas envie.
Sa couleur verte est due au taux
de phospore très élevé engendré
par l'activité humaine au fil
des ans. Les bactéries et
les plantes, comme le
myriophylle à épis s'en
nourissent et le lac est
aujourd'hui eutrophe,
c'est-à-dire asphyxié.
- On a une bouée indicatrice
ici qui mentionne "myriophylle
à épis". Ce qu'on veut indiquer
c'est qu'il y a un îlot là qu'on
va voir apparaître à la surface
de l'eau à la fi à la fin du mo.
- Il prévoit poser de nombreuses
autres bouées dans les prochains
jours.
- Les riverains là-bas
sont rendus à à peu près
200-250 pieds de leur berge.
Ils ne peuvent plus sortir
à partir du mois de juillet.
Ils peuvent plus sortir en
chaloupe ou en quoique ce soit
parce qu'ils sont accotés.
- Le lac Maskinongé
a perdu son attrait d'antan.
- Malheureusement, ce qui
est véhiculé comme information
aux nouveaux acheteurs, souvent,
c'est erroné. Puis, ils vont
s'en apercevoir quand il vont
avoir mis les deux pieds dans
le lac.
- Selon Québec, 203 lacs de
la province sont aujourd'hui
aux prises avec le myriophylle
à épis, dont 46 dans
les Laurentides.
RICHARD CARIGNAN, prof.
retraité, spécialiste lacs, UdeM
- Généralement, nos lacs sont
en bonne condition, mais
que d'année en année
ils s'aggravent.
- Richard Carignan a étudié
les lacs du Québec
sa carrière :
- Si vous avez amené dans
un lac trop d'éléments
nutritifs, si vous avez
encourag
du myriophylle à épis,
comptez une quarantaine d'années
après l'instauration de bonnes
pratiques pour que ça revienne
comme c'était avant.
- Il faut préserver les bandes
littorales, améliorer
les installations septiques
et limiter l'étalement urbain.
Tout en espérant que ceux
qui passent d'un lac à l'autre
nettoieront leur bateau.
- La clôture est ouverte. Et
puis, il n'y a aucun contrôle!
- Le lac Cameron, où habite
François Jacob, à Amherst,
résiste encore aux espèces
envahiss
combien de temps?
FRANÇOIS JACOB, résident,
Lac Cameron
- Ça peut se faire en l'espace
de 5 ans. On sait qu'il y enns .
On le sait qu'il y a
des motomarines qui passent
sur des terrains privés.
On veut pas interdire l'accès ae
les gens lavent leur bateau.
Puis qu'il y ait une certaine
vérification au poste de lavage
du bateau.
- On a beau vouloir protéger
les lacs, c'est parfois
difficile d'être optimiste :
- Il y a des causes importantes
qui sont
comme les hydravions, par
exemple. Un hydravion peut
facilement amerrir sur un lac ms
et se poser sur un autre lac.
- Il y en a une qui est partie
ce matin. Ces gens-là, ça
s'en va dans le nord.
Ils ont des camps de chasse,
des pourvoiries. On les voit
passer dans les airs avec
ces herbes-là attachées à
leur gouvernail. Qu'est-ce qui
va arriver à ce futur lac-là?
- Et comme rien n'est
simple, l'eau des lacs est
de juridiction fédérale,
les fonds marins sont
au provincial et
les infrastructures
sont mun